llega un camión del depósito de
cadáveres de la ciudad de lucha en su
interior los restos de 20 cuerpos sin
identificar
es el tercer entierro de este tipo en el
cementerio de la ciudad en la última
semana
el olor de los cuerpos en descomposición
se siente en el aire
[Música]
el padre andrew está solo entre los
muertos no hay familiares que lloran su
muerte
para mí bueno
mientras los entierran él está aquí para
asegurarse de que no sean olvidados
y tú muy buenas es muy importante para
nosotros enterrarlos con dignidad no
solo enterrarlos como cuerpos sino
enterrarlos como personas con la
esperanza de la resurrección de los
muertos muertos los trabajos para
identificar los cuerpos continúan cada
tumba está marcada con un número que
enlaza con una base de datos que tiene
el adn de la víctima todavía no se le ha
dado un nombre de 50 de ellas
aquí en lucha y creo que en toda ucrania
no estábamos preparados para una
cantidad tan grande de cuerpos de
personas que fueron asesinadas en tan
poco tiempo por fan
seis meses después masacre en lucha lo
que hemos visto hoy aquí en el
cementerio es el comienzo de un proceso
de cierre pero no estará completo hasta
que se haya identificado hasta el último
cuerpo y se informe a los familiares